اللي في جيبك مو لك لوحدك هذه العباره
حقيقيه بصراحه وواقع في هذه الايام ايش
رايك
بس
انت كرجل وزوج اللي بجيبك مش لالك تحول
تحول الاب الى
الزمن الصعب مشاه
دينا
كل يوم تجبرنا على التفكير اكثر بابنائنا
ومستقبلينهم في الحقيقه الادخار لاجل
الابناء مسؤوليه اضافيه على الاهل خصوصا
انهم ربما لا يرغبون بمرور ابنائهم ببعض
الظروف التي عانوا منها او مروا فيها لكن
كيف يمكن ان يتم هذا الادخار وتحقيق دخل
يكفي كمصاريف لهم في مستقبلهم اليوم
سنتعرف على بعض هذه النصائح في سبيل ادخار
وامان مالي لاجل الابناء في المستقبل
ينضم الينا في الاستديو وائل مكارم الخبير
الاقتصادي والمحلله الاستثماري يا صباح
الخير يسعد صباح الخير
الاولاد والمال مجبنه الرجال كما قلنا لكن
فرعون الاخيره ربما تحول الاب الى انه
بابا نويل اما يجيب هدايا او اي تي ام
مشين انه يعطي الاولاد لكن في شيء يؤرق
دائما هو مستقبل اولاده وحتى الام ترى حتى
لا
معلش
كيف الواحد يوفر صحيح هذه وحده من اهم
الاسئله يعني كل الاشخاص بيسالوك اياها
وخاصه يعني مع صعوبه الزمن كلنا بنعرف
الغلاء المعيش اللي عم بيصير تضخم حول
العالم خلال السنتين اللي مركوا فكل
الاشخاص هلا بيسالك شو احسن شي بدي استثمر
فيه لاولادي وما في مثل يعني ما في خلص
نموذج وهذا هو الاساسي في طبعا عده خيارات
متاحه ولكن كمان طريقه الادخار او كميه
الادخار بتفرق من من عيله لعيله من الظروف
قدرتهم طبيعه العمل شو الحياه اللي
بيرغبوها لابنائهم كخيارات في خيارات جدا
متاحه يعني
[موسيقى]
الامد لانه من الافضل انه نبلش حتى لو
الاطفال كانوا صغار نبلش نتدخل
كل الوقت مبكر كل مكان افضل ولكن شو هي
الاستثمارات او خيارات الاستثمارات على
المدى الطويل هل مثلا العقارات افضل ام
نحط وديعه في البنك ام بنشتري اراضي لانه
بدنا اياها ريعها يعني راح
اعطيك اياها بشكل مبسط ونرجع ننتقل على
هون هي الاساس انه انت تقدري تزيد الولف
تبعك او تزيد الحفظ المالي والماديات اللي
عندك اياها لحتى تقدري بعدين شو ما كنت
فيك تحطيهم بقصص يعني في عندك
بيستعملوا فقط يعني حسابات توفيرستعملوا
حسابات عليها عوائد مثلا ثابته لفتره
بعيده في كثير الرائج مثلا انه انت بتحطي
تفتح حساب بتحطي بالتعليم يعني بتصير
تزيدي لهم كل شهر
افضل افضل
يعني بيختلف طبعا بين ناحيه الامان بتروحي
ساعتها فقط بتحطي وديعه في البنك وبتاخذي
عليها فايده اذا بدك تاخذي مخاطره وهذا
الشيء يلي راقش مثلا في العالم برا بتروحي
مثلا على مؤش عندك مثلا اهم 500 شركه لن
اعتبر مثل
15 شركه في العالم صحيح بتكون انت يعني
على فتره مثلا كل شهر بتقطعي مبلغ شو ما
كان السعر وبتحط فيهم لانه بتعتبري انه هو
انت بتعتبري انه هو الشركات على عشره او
15 وعشرين سنه راح يكونوا هن اهم شركات في
العالم وهن اصلا اهم شركات في العالم
مع نمو الاقتصاد اكثر واكثر عالميا قيمتهم
راح تزيد فما انه قيمتهم راح تزيد يعني
قيمه استثمارك راح يزيد وهذه تاريخيا يعني
ثابته وائل اليوم البعض يفكر بانه هناك
ايضا عروض ومغريات انه والله تعال اشتري
اسهم او وفر لاولادك حتى نضمن لك منحه
مستقبليه للجامعه هذا واحد اثنين كيف اني
انا ادخل واقتطع هذا المبلغ دون ان يؤثر
على اولادي الان لانه حتى التعليم الان
وهم في الصغار اصبح غالي شكرا انك قويت
على اول نقطه لازم كتير ننتبه عليها هاي
لانه اليوم على السوشيال ميديا بتشوفوا
كتير داعيات لناس بيقعدوا بالارب
مستقبلا هيدا معظمه يعني اول ما تشوف وعود
بدك تحط علامات استفهام وبدك تدقق اكثر
وبدك تروح على شركات يعني مهمه
ورقبتها كتير منيحه بالنسبه لكيف تقتطع
يعني ما في ما في كمان نرجع نعيد ما في
مثل كوتا معينه مثل ما بيقولوا لك عشرين
بالميه
مش صحيحه هذا الشيء هذا بيعتمد على كل فرد
وظروف عم يمر فيها وكيف ممكن انه مثل عم
تفضل ما في انا لانه لازم اعمل ادخار اكون
عن بوكس اشياء من حياتي ممكن هي تكون عم
تعطيني استثمار حاله لحتى يساعدني اعمل
ادخار بعدين
يجب استثمار ما هو فائض وكل عائله وكل شخص
على حسب ما يناسبه شكرا جزيلا لك
مكارم خبير اقتصاديه في ومحلل استثمار كان
معنا في الاستديو شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات